Wir wollen sprechen über Nationalismus und andere Tendenzen dieser Art bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Ein großes Thema, wir wollen es zumindest anreißen und die Frage beantworten. Hat das jetzt zugenommen oder ist das vielleicht auch selektive Wahrnehmung? Und was sind vor allem die Folgen daraus? Das werde ich jetzt hier besprechen, in diesem Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch mit Ruben Gerczikow, Publizist und Autor und mit Inga Hofmann vom Tagesspiegel jetzt hier im Rasenfunk.
Was man sagen kann ist, dass hoch emotionale Momente bei großen internationalen Turnieren im Fußball, einem Sport, der ja nun wirklich die Gesellschaft durchdringt, dass diese Momente vielleicht wie Fotos sind von einer mehr oder weniger gelungenen Familienfeier, die man dann ins Album klebt und das ist ja auch schon was. Man kann sich dran erinnern und man macht das Album auf und sagt, guck mal, wie jung wir damals waren und es war ein glücklicher Moment und das war möglich. Also das ist so ziemlich das Maximum im Zusammenhalt, was der Fußball heute schaffen kann, aber das ist auch nicht nichts.
Ja, Co-Gastgeber finde ich auch eine kreative Idee. Und es war schon Wahnsinn zu beobachten, wie viele Fans der jeweiligen Mannschaften in den Stadien waren. Es waren ja ganze einfarbige Blöcke. Das war schon sehr eindrucksvoll zu sehen. Und es gab ja auch dieses friedliche Beieinander zusammen Feiern auf den Fan-Mayen. Gab es das ja in Teilen auch. Also ja, diese Bilder bleiben. Und an denen kann man das Bild auch ein bisschen festhalten.
Das ist eben der eine Aspekt dieses Turniers. Und dann hat Bluten Oli noch einen weiteren mitgebracht im Forum. Er schreibt, müssen wir es nicht einfach aushalten, wenn der türkische Nachbar im Gespräch beim Hecke schneiden mir erklärt, welche Bedeutung der Gruß der grauen Wölfe für ihn hat. Und erst dann, sofern die Deutung Richtung graue Wölfe geht, es kritisch anmerken und diskutieren. Also sprich, Ruben, hier wird mal thematisiert, ob wir nicht auch mehr miteinander reden sollten. Und vielleicht auch manchmal mit Leuten reden sollten, von denen wir erstmal annehmen, dass wir ihre Meinung ablehnen. Oder vielleicht auch ihre Meinung offen ablehnen. Wie denkst du darüber?
Ich glaube, damit macht man sich es zu einfach. Und ja, es gibt die Bezüge zur Mythologie natürlich. Gleichermaßen hat auch das Hakenkreuz eine andere Bedeutung gehabt, bevor es die Nationalsozialistinnen instrumentalisiert bzw. missbraucht haben. Und ich glaube, im Kontext der Grauen Wölfe kann man durchaus sagen, dass der Wolfsgruß eben nicht nur ein Verweis auf die Mythologie und auf die Geburtsstunde des Türkentums zurückzuführen ist, sondern eben auch durch die Ülkücü-Bewegung für eine nationalistisch-rassistische Ideologie steht, die in der Vergangenheit Gewalttaten zu morden, wie ich anfangs gesagt habe, auch hier in Deutschland, da ist. Und als jemand, der selber schon Morddrohungen von Grauen Wölfen erhalten hat, kann ich das in der Art und Weise nicht so sehen, ebenso wie viele andere türkisch-stämmige Menschen in Deutschland. Von daher weiß ich nicht, ob man das aushalten muss.
Ja, du hast quasi jetzt am Schluss das Punkt zu einem Blutenolli ausgesetzt. Ich glaube auch, wenn solche Haltung erkennbar werden, und ich meine, wir alle versammeln uns vor dem universellen Anspruch der Menschenrechte, an dem wir uns aber auch selber messen müssen, dann ist es ja klar, dass man das nicht aushalten muss, in Anführungszeichen, aber das miteinander reden und das nachfragen, fand ich einen interessanten Gedanke, weil ich hatte das Gefühl, dass es sehr schnell bei dieser EM so war, und jetzt vor allem jetzt im Fall der Türkei, dass wir über andere geredet haben und eben viel zu wenig gefragt haben, wie denkt ihr selbst darüber? Und dann, wenn man dann eine Antwort bekommt, die eben nicht auf dem Basis unserer Werte, also unserer jetzt in großen Anführungszeichen basiert, ja klar, dann, also man muss nicht alles akzeptieren. Das wollte ich damit nicht sagen. Ich denke, das wollte auch Olli in dem Fall nicht sagen. Aber ich glaube, das war der Aspekt. Inga, hast du da noch Gedanken dazu?
Naja, ich glaube, dahinter steht eine relativ große Debatte. Aber miteinander reden, diskutieren und die Debatten auch führen, ist glaube ich total wichtig. Und beim Thema Zuhören, Betroffenen zuhören, also Menschen, die von der Gewalt, die von den grauen Wölfen ausgeht, zuhören. Diese Stimmen auch in Runden, den Gehör verschaffen, zu Sichtbarkeit beitragen. Ich glaube, das sind ganz zentrale Punkte. Aber ja, ich bin immer auch dafür, da im Dialog zu bleiben. Aber natürlich bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt.
Und dazu hat, und das wäre jetzt dann der letzte Aspekt, den ich noch gerne kurz mit euch besprechen würde, Mac Crab auch was geschrieben im Forum. Er sagt nämlich, er oder sie, ich weiß es nicht, was immer wir sehen, der Wolfsgruß ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, ist doch nur eine sehr oberflächliche, schlaglichtartige Reflektion einer viel tiefer gehenden Debatte oder eines viel tiefer in der Gesellschaft ablaufenden Prozesses. Nur dass die emotionale Eskalation bei so einem großen Turnier diese Vorgänge, die auch ohne EM genauso abläufen würden, völlig verzerrt. Mit anderen Worten, der überall sich wieder abzeichnende Stärkung, die sich überall wieder abzeichnende Stärkung einer nationalen Selbstwahrnehmung in breiten Bevölkerungsschichten ist ein super interessantes und wichtiges Thema. Aber was dann bei der EM passiert, ist nur sensationell und geht nicht im Geringsten an die Wurzeln dieser Entwicklung ran. Ich halte jedenfalls nichts von der These, dass Fußballturniere diesbezüglich eine Wirkungskraft entfalten können. Sie sind immer nur symptomatisch. Ruben, du hast schon sehr viel genickt. Ich habe das Gefühl, hier Zustimmung herauszusehen.
Das Stadion ist Brennglas der Gesellschaft. Die Sachen, die wir in der Gesellschaft erleben, zeigen sich auch noch mal versteckt im Stadion. Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass der Fußball diese integrative Wirkung haben kann und auch dementsprechend gesellschaftspolitische Diskussionen anstoßen kann. Das sieht man allein schon, wie viele beispielsweise Bundesligavereine sich zu gesellschaftlichen Themen äußern. Vereine, die eigene Laufgruppen beim Christopher-Street-Day organisieren, sich am Gedenktag, am 27. Januar, am Gedenktag für die Opfer des Nationalsozialismus engagieren. Also ich glaube schon, dass der Fußball auch eine Wirkung hat, die weit über das Stadion hinausgehen kann. Deswegen stimme ich der Person bis zum Ende absolut zu, dass der Fußball sein kann, weil der Fußball ist zwar eine politische Plattform, meiner Meinung nach, aber er ist trotzdem auch nicht die Plattform, auf der wir tatsächlich fachgerecht auch über Politik sprechen sollten, weil dafür gibt es andere Kanäle, dafür gibt es Diskussionsrunden, dafür gibt es die Parlamente, dafür gibt es Parteien. Aber der Fußball trägt meiner Meinung nach definitiv einen Teil zu dieser Debatte bei.
Inga, deckt sich das mit deiner Meinung?
Und ich glaube, der Beitrag passt auch gut zu dem, was wir schon gesagt haben. Also, dass schon seit Jahren Personen versuchen, auf die Problematik der Grauen Wölfe, auf die Gefahr, die von ihnen ausgeht, aufmerksam zu machen und es einfach kaum gehört wird, dass es kaum Sensibilisierung für das Thema gibt. Und jetzt aber der Aufschrei sehr groß ist. Also, ich glaube, dass dieser Aspekt der Symptomatik da auch sehr zutreffend ist.
Ja, und es ist interessant, wenn man vor allem dann mal den größeren Bogen spannt. Also, ich habe da vor dieser Sendung drüber nachgedacht, weil ich eben viel über die Rolle der Medien nachgedacht habe, bei dieser Europameisterschaft, welche Rolle eigentlich der Rasenfunk und das, was ich hier getan habe in den letzten Jahren, einnimmt. Und man kann da eigentlich schon den größeren Bogen spannen. Zu EM 2016 kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass wir hier im Rasenfunk so wirklich die großen politischen und sociologischen Diskussionen geführt haben. Spätestens mit der WM 2018, wo ich aber schon ein halbes Jahr vorher angefangen habe, mit Katrin Scheib regelmäßig zu sprechen. Da haben wir viel gesprochen über Menschenrechte, über zivilgesellschaftlichen Aktivismus, wie der zur Zeit der WM in Teilen zurückgedrängt wurde, in Teilen aber auch zugelassen wurde und was dann aber auch danach nicht passiert ist. Und ich glaube, ausgehend von diesen Gesprächen kann man dann ganz gut einen Bogen spannen. Es wurde immer mehr. Die WM in Katta hat natürlich dazu eingeladen. Es hat dazu geführt, dass sie auch hier im Rasenfunk boykottiert wurde. Und jetzt ist das kein Höhepunkt, aber ich glaube, für mich steht das in einer Reihe, was wir jetzt gerade hier besprochen haben. Mein Eindruck ist, dass vielleicht die große Entwicklung unserer Zeit ist, dass sich gesellschaftliche Probleme so verschärfen, dass wir auch im Fußball immer schlechter drum herumkommen und dass wir aber auch aus anderen Gründen auch noch darüber sprechen wollen und auch den Fußball an seinen eigenen Worten messen wollen. Denn der Fußball behauptet immer unpolitisch zu sein, aber diese Diskussion, damit will ich gar nicht mehr einsteigen. Wer das noch behauptet im Jahr 2024, der braucht auch den Rest dieser Sendung nicht hören. Deswegen wollte ich diese Frage zum Eingang gar nicht stellen. Da sind wir uns alle einig und da versichern wir uns nur gegenseitig, wie richtig wir das sehen. Aber das ist eben, glaube ich, so die große Linie, die man vollführen kann. Und da wird diese EM aber auch dann wieder ein Beispiel sein. Also wir werden, ich weiß nicht in welcher Art, aber wir werden zur Weltmeisterschaft darüber sprechen. Wir werden ganz sicher im Bereich des Frauenfußballs noch oft über solche Themen sprechen, weil die da nämlich ganz anders thematisiert werden. Total interessanter Aspekt. Diese Turniere habe ich jetzt gerade ausgespart, weil wir da über solche Aspekte gar nicht sprechen mussten bisher. Vielleicht kommt das aber auch mehr. Also das ist doch interessant. Und da sehe ich dann auch quasi diese Sendung, die nur ein Ausschnitt sein kann einer Debatte, die man aber dann in einem größeren Kontext sehen muss und die ganz sicherlich in zukünftigen Sendungen, die in einem halben Jahr, in einem Jahr, vielleicht auch in zwei Jahren erscheinen, glaube ich dann ihren Widerhall finden. Deswegen danke ich euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch darauf eingelassen habt. Es war kein einfaches Thema, das zu besprechen. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Inga Hofmann. Folgt ihr sehr gerne auf Twitter, auf Mastodon. Ich werde alles verlinken. Danke, dass du mal im Rasenfunk warst. Das hat mich eigentlich mit am meisten gefreut.
Ja, ich habe mich auch sehr gefreut. Vielen, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Sehr, sehr gerne, jederzeit wieder. Und genauso geht das raus an Ruben Gerczikow. Ganz herzlichen Dank auch für deine Arbeit. Das möchte ich noch mal ausdrücklich sagen, weil eben du ganz wesentlich dafür mitverantwortlich bist, dass auch die in Anführungszeichen kleineren Vorfälle, also die, die leichter nicht in der Öffentlichkeit stattgefunden hätten, schon thematisiert wurden, bevor dann die in Anführungszeichen großen Vorfälle kamen, die auch zu Sanktionen geführt haben und deswegen logischerweise überall thematisiert wurden. Also vielen Dank für deine Arbeit, Publizist und Autor Ruben Gerczikow. Und ich danke dann auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Ich werde noch ein paar Links in die Show Notes packen zu dieser Sendung. Zum einen natürlich einen tollen Artikel von Harald, den habe ich glaube schon zweimal jetzt empfohlen bei dieser EM, wo er eben viele, viele Fälle auflistet, auch mit Ruben gesprochen hat in diesem Beitrag. Ich werde ein Deutschlandfunk-Sportgespräch verlinken, auch auf jeden Fall die Quelle des Zitats von Albrecht Sonntag. Und der Balabalabalkang-Podcast hat auch eine total interessante Folge gemacht, vor allem interessiert, also interessant fand ich vor allem an dieser Folge, die Emotionalität, mit der dort die vorliegenden Fälle diskutiert wurden und die These eines der Beteiligten, der gesagt hat, warum soll ich das überhaupt noch gucken, wenn die alle ihr nationalistisches Spiel draus machen aus dieser EM. Hat bei mir viele Gedanken angeregt, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das auch bei euch passiert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, also hört sehr gerne auch in diese Folge rein. Es wird alles verlinkt in den Show Notes und ich freue mich auch schon über die Diskussion hierzu. Ich musste mich manchmal ein bisschen verbiegen in meiner Rolle als Moderator. Ich hoffe, ihr legt mir das nicht so negativ aus, aber gut, ich werde es aushalten müssen. Und dann danke ich natürlich als letztes noch allen, die mit ihrer Unterstützung diese Sendung hier möglich gemacht haben. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Alles im Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Und auch deshalb können wir die Themen hier so setzen, in der Art und Weise, wie wir wollen. Hier redet niemand rein, außer Frank und ich, die die Entscheidung treffen, was wir hier machen. Das heißt, herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns unterstützt haben. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Nicolas, bei dem Unterstützer, den ich persönlich am liebsten habe, bei Jan Grobi, bei Prisemuth und bei Läuft bei mir, Daniel. Das heißt, ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. rasenfunk.de/supportersclubist die Adresse eurer Wahl. Und unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de. Ihr könnt noch den allerletzten Merch des Rasenfunks kaufen. Und wir wissen nicht, ob oder wann es noch mal Merch geben wird. Ist gerade 50 Prozent reduziert. Wir lösen unser Lager auf. Helft uns dabei, dass dieses Lager dann auch wirklich nicht mehr existiert. Also zumindest nichts mehr vom Rasenfunk in diesem Lager existiert. kiosk.rasenfunk.de In diesem Sinne, hier im Rasenfunk geht's natürlich noch weiter mit der sportlichen Berichterstattung. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich wieder. Bis dahin bleibt gesund und macht's gut.
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.